there's a group of scientists that has
just discovered
that there is no biological basis
for transgenderism
can you believe that these people get
paid to do this
can you imagine how much these
scientists got paid the funding they had
to conduct this study to know what every
three-year-old knows that's amazing but
it's good that they're doing it because
our culture is so crazy that it takes
courageous scientists to go out and buck
the politically correct Norm but this is
an international group of over 100
clinicians and researchers who have
attested that there is no biological
evidence for gender identity they've
they've observed that no Laboratory test
can distinguish a trans-identified
person from a non-trans identified
person what they write quote
the Assumption of the core biological
underpinning for gender identity and
gender dysphoria remains an unproven
Theory
while biology likely plays a role in
gender non-conformity currently there is
no brain blood or other objective test
that distinguishes a trans identified
from a non-trans identified person once
confounding factors such as sexual
orientation meaning desire are a
controlled form this is according to the
society for evidence-based gender
medicine okay I'm glad that they're
debunking this idea that you'll
sometimes hear this among the most
eccentric and incoherent transgender
activists they'll say well you know the
brain
of a man who identifies as a woman it's
actually closer to a woman's brain
which is funny because the libs for
years told us there's no difference
between the brains of men and women do
you remember that
do you remember in the days of feminism
when we were told there absolutely no
the only differences between boys and
girls is that is a few secondary sex
characteristics but the brains are
exactly the same how dare you say that
women have different brains than men
until they wanted transgenderism and
they said no of course the brains are
totally different but there's never been
any scientific evidence for that the
reason that that some transgender
activists have made that argument is
because they're materialists and they're
atheists and they don't believe in the
soul and they don't believe in
metaphysics and so they can't discuss
these these issues of anthropology in a
sophisticated way the only thing they
can talk about is just stuff and matter
so they they have to ground the soul
which is what they're really trying to
talk about in something physical and
they know they can't ground it in the
the visible physical attributes of a
person so they say oh yeah somewhere in
the brain yeah somewhere in the brain
that you can't see that's where you find
out that a boy's really a girl but that
that never made sense and the more
serious and intellectual transgender
activists will be more honest and what
they will say is there's a difference
between sex and gender
and sex is your physical state and
gender is your non-physical state so you
physically you could be a man but
metaphysically you're a woman
what they're really talking about there
is the soul
and
these guys are a little more
sophisticated and intellectual in the
way that they're talking about it but it
still doesn't hold up because then you
have to ask okay well what is the
relationship to the body and and the
soul and the relationship between the
body and the soul is that the soul is
the substantial form of the body
that the body is a symbol of the soul
and so the two are linked and the
technical term for this is hylomorphism
this is how Aristotle describes the
relationship between
form and matter between the metaphysical
stuff and the physical stuff and very
quickly not to go down a long discourse
on Ancient Greek philosophy but very
quickly this
conversation goes over the heads of the
transgender promoters because they they
want to talk about the soul when it
gives them some way of justifying their
absurd idea that a man can really be a
woman but they they don't want to go so
far as to have a serious conversation
about the soul they're not capable of
doing that because when you when you do
that when you when you raise this
possibility that the the soul is
entirely different from the body that
the soul can be in total opposition to
the body
their argument I think at that point
falls apart but then it especially falls
apart because if you're saying okay
these two things are entirely distinct
and you want to bring them into
Conformity with one another well then
that raises the obvious question okay if
my soul is one thing and my body is this
other thing
why do I have to change my body
why can't I just change my soul
why can't I just change my mind is
really the question that comes up if I
if I'm a man I look like a man and I but
my mind tells me that I'm a woman well
just change my mind I change my mind
about things all the time
I go I say hey I want sushi for lunch
and then my buddy says hey actually I
want to get burritos I say okay let's
get burritos there we go I just changed
my mind
it's very easy to change your mind it's
very hard to change your body it
requires extremely painful surgeries
extremely expensive surgeries
sterilizing yourself grafting off your
skin from your legs and your arms to
create this grotesque caricature of of
genitalia why don't you just change your
mind all of that falls apart
all of which to say getting back to the
scientific document debunking the
biological basis for gender identity
yeah obviously that's true obviously
there's no biological basis for these
sexual delusions of boys who think
they're girls it's important to
establish that
but it doesn't answer the question
the question of transgenderism is not is
it physical
the question of transgenderism is is it
real
yes I know gender identity is not in
your brain somewhere it's not in your
hands it's not yes but
not every real thing is physical
love language geometry
most things that we hold dear are not
physical but they are nonetheless real
so I think conservatives have fallen
into this trap too and I suspect a lot
of these scientists are relatively
conservative compared to the culture and
they want to ground everything following
the Enlightenment and following the
Scientific Revolution and following
modern liberalism they want to ground
every single thing in something physical
and say well if it's not physical if I
can't see it under a microscope then
it's not real
okay I guess that will help you make
certain calculations about certain
physical phenomena but most of the stuff
that we care about in the world is not
physical
we all behave every moment of every day
as if we believe that there is more to
the world than just the physical world
so then then we have to ask ourselves
okay what is the nature of the
metaphysical world and is there such a
thing as gender identity there is the
soul totally distinct from the body what
what religion are we living under okay
and and because we for most of our
country's history we took those
questions seriously and came to
relatively reasonable conclusions about
that namely
various interpretations of Christianity
some far more precise some a little less
precise but that was what animated our
country that's where our founding
fathers said that's what the men who
developed not only our country but our
civilization said okay I get that that
gives me a grounding of of who we are
and what we're all doing here together
as that has fallen apart
because of our ignorance and sin and
vice as that has fallen apart now we're
very very confused and men are chopping
off their genitals and equally confused
men are taking the oath of office and
the U.S Congress on a comic book not
great speaking of getting back to
Christianity
Bible in a year which you've heard me
mention on the show many times heard me
mention today
Bible in a year remains one of the top
podcasts in the country
Bible in a year right now is the number
three podcast in the country according
to the charts
do you know what the number two podcast
is
the Bible recap which is another Bible
podcast this one put out by D group
do you know what the number one podcast
in the country is
catechism in a year also with father
Mike Schmitz who does Bible linear
this one Catholic priest is the host of
two of the three most popular podcasts
in the country
one of which is on the Bible one of
which is on the catechism of the
Catholic Church
and then the podcast that's wedged right
in the middle of those two is the top
three
is also a Bible podcast this is great
news I know there's all terrible news in
the culture and in the politics
this is great news
what that tells me is not
that our country is totally fine right
now
not that actually we're still a serious
Christian country that has our act
together it doesn't tell me that
but it tells me that there is a longing
in the country
to return to that which is true and good
and beautiful there is a lung we're not
there right now
if we lived in a country that had its
act together
spiritually personally politically
I suspect that Bible in a year and
catechism in a year probably wouldn't be
the top three podcasts
I suspect there you you might have some
religion shows as the top podcast you
might have you might it might be father
Mike Schmitz but they would be they
would be more advanced they would be on
the lives of the Saints they would be on
the doctors of the church they would be
on on more
technical aspects of the faith I think
probably because we would all we would
all know our Bible really really well we
would all know the catechism really
really well
the Bible in your podcast is I mean it's
edifying for people who've been in the
church their whole lives but it's also
totally acceptable to people who are
just questioning who don't even know
what they believe catechism in a year is
the is that primer okay what does it
mean to be in the church what does the
church say what is the church taught for
two thousand years it's
it's totally open and accessible and can
be very basic for people which is a
wonderful thing because it's people who
have been raised basically without
religion
who recognize wow
something has gone horribly wrong here
some whatever I don't know what it was
but something broke in the last 70 years
and I want to I want to get back to that
thing that we lost that's one that's
absolutely great news the rest of the
show continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member right now it is fake headline
Friday I need your help to to guide me
along as Virgil guided Dante as I try to
discern which of the five headlines that
my producer Ben Davies has given me is
the fake headlines so head on over to
daily wire.com use code Knowles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans daily wire.com Knowles
[Music]
foreign
[Music]